I wanted to say like on this kind of
we're on this topic of opportunities you
get you know kind of when you get a
platform
so one of the reasons kind of I railed a
little bit earlier against um
materialism or whatever I think to the
extent to which you can moderate your
own greed
you can play longer term games and I
think so many people end up cutting and
otherwise promising career short by just
wanting it too fast so I think it's like
a huge Edge just like discipline is in
terms of like achieving what you want I
think I'm like a very moderate like
being comfortable with a moderate
existence and finding happiness in that
is a huge Edge because really your
overhead is so much cheaper than the
people who need a Ferrari or a super
nice house to feel fulfilled and when
your overhead is less you have the
luxury to say no to like sketchy offers
that the different you have freedom that
other people don't have because
a lot of times people don't pitch it
this way they pitch a Ferrari as Freedom
or like a big houses like you've made it
in a lot of ways those shackle you back
to like you gotta find the cash flow for
those things it's never a free ride yeah
that's really beautifully put I I've
always said that I had [ __ ] you money at
the very beginning I was broke for most
of my life
the way you have [ __ ] you money is by
not needing much to say [ __ ] you that's
that's the threat I mean that's the
overhead that you're talking about if
you can live if you can live simply and
be truly happy and be truly free I think
that means
um that means you could be free at any
in any kind of situation you could make
the wise kind of decisions and in that
case money
uh enables you in certain ways to do
more cool stuff but it doesn't shackle
you like you said too many people in the
society would shackle because material
possession is kind of like draw you into
this race
um of uh more and more and more and more
and then you feel the burden of that
bigger houses and all that kind of stuff
and now now you have to keep working now
you have to keep doing this thing